the clock is counting down to the first
rocket launch from the UK to put
satellites in orbit the journey to space
will start on a jumbo jet Cosmic girl
once flew two and a half million
passengers more than 8 000 flights
across the Atlantic now she carries a 21
meter rocket under her Wing called
launcher one at the moment she's parked
up at Spaceport Cornwall at Newquay
airport but in a few hours she'll fly to
a drop zone off the south coast of
Ireland where she'll do circuits of what
virgin orbit call the racetrack while
Engineers carry out final checks then a
35 000 feet the pilot will lift up the
aircraft's nose to point the rocket in
the right direction and release it from
the wing after a four second Free Fall
the engine will fire taking launcher one
to eight thousand miles an hour past
Portugal and into space at an altitude
of 350 miles it will release nine
satellites about the size of a toaster
one is testing components for a future
space Factory another will look for
illegal fishing trafficking and piracy
so why is this a big deal well Britain
builds more satellites than anywhere
outside California but they will no
longer need to be sent as far away as
New Zealand now they can be launched
from Cornwall and from next year space
ports on Mainland Scotland and the
shetlands being the first in Western
Europe to have a launch pad could add
3.8 billion pounds to the economy over
the next decade
but as with every rocket launch there is
some Jeopardy this will be the fifth
mission for launcher one the first a
test flight failed to reach space after
the engine cut out
the rest have been successful but there
are still strict safety rules this time
there's an exclusion Zone around the
airport in case of an explosion an
aircraft and ships are being told to
keep clear of the launch area in the
Atlantic but this is just the start with
rocket launches soon routine as Cornwall
joins the space race